Hello, Dr. Kevin Connors here for your next bird-minute talking about Lyme disease
chronic Lyme disease is what do we do with a cute Lyme disease we kill it with an antibiotic gets
your medical doctor talk to about your symptoms find somebody that's Lyme literate don't wait because
your window of opportunity for a killer can be really short and then it becomes a bear and we don't
like to do that so chronic Lyme disease becomes an autoimmune disorder so autoimmune disorder that
means your body's immune system your th2 side is starting to create antibodies against your
own cells not good so an autoimmune disorder remember you have a th1 side and a th2 side
you get stuck in a imbalance either a hyper th1 imbalance or a hyper th2 imbalance but not both
most of the time if if you have a chronic Lyme a chronic Lyme patient walks in my office and
they're th2 dominant they're stuck at a th2 dominant disorder really they don't walk in my office
because they already found some nutritionists that's local they already you know read about cats claw
or they started taking garlic or echinacea or something like that all those things all those immune
stimulants what side of this is both this is the immune system here what does what do all those
things the cats claw garlic echinacea one of those golden seal what do they stimulate they stimulate
a th1 response because these are the killers this is the Marine Corps with the machine guns
these guys are the ones that mainly destroy the pathogens what does the th2 cytokines do
well they do some of that but mainly they're responsible for creating antibodies so that these guys
can find it and go kill it if a person is th2 dominant they don't typically walk in my office
because if you do take cats claw and echinacea and garlic and things like that you can kill it
so the problem with Lyme chronic Lyme disease patients that have had chronic Lyme disease as a
destroy their life for the last five 10 15 years is that they are th1 dominant so their th1 side
is ramped up so if they go to a practitioner are they take cats claw or they take a garlic
where they do some regimen that's going to stimulate in the immune response in the hope to hope here's
my beautiful protocol that's going to kill this thing you can kill the bacteria for a period of time
but you just ramp this up through the rough so what are you doing you already have antibodies
against self tissue and now you're giving fuel to the marine corps that is killing self tissue you're
going to be in a hurt mood so you got your immune system that even act that is even destroying your
body you're fueling the destruction of your body that's the bottom line so what do you do with
chronic Lyme you don't do these things do not take th1 stimulants hello you heard it to your first
maybe not first but i hope you got a practitioner that's well versed in the immune response
because if you're taking th1 stimulants and you have chronic Lyme that's not good don't do that
so we're going to talk more about how you deal with this then a little tricky stay tuned